- You've done well acting in comedies.
So, like "The Office," I
know that happened as well,
so how did you end up doing "The Office?"
How did that
audition-
- Well, "The Office,"
I've been doing normal auditions,
I found out how you really get a job,
and that is, you have tape of you
and one of the cast members on something.
(Kelly laughing)
- Like blackmail?
- You for it, a little bit like blackmail.
(all laughing)
(audience clapping)
(Kelly clapping)
Rainn Wilson and I,
about seven or eight years
(Kelly laughing)
before that, (chuckling)
did a pilot called "The Expendables,"
where we played androids
that solved crimes.
And we were like
(Kelly's voice drowns)
robotic but very human.
We spent I think a good 30% of it naked
and charging like this.
- Again what?
(guest laughing)
(audience laughing)
(guest clapping)
- Just shooting above that.
And so, when I got there,
I did the whole audition,
and one of the producers said,
"So, I understand you're
friends with Rainn?"
And I said, "Yeah! Did
he tell you how we met?"
And he goes, "No,"
and I go, (chuckling) "I bet he didn't."
(all laughing)
So, I told them, and they
were losing their minds
to try to picture Rainn
bein', and he was amazing,
and it's so funny, but we were like,
I am starting to have feelings,
kind of thing like that.
- [Guest] Oh my. (laughs)
- And I said, "So, I have that,
but not only that, if I get
this job, day one, I show up
with a DVD of that pilot
that I will give to you."
And I was not even in my
car, and my phone rang,
(chuckling) and I was like, "Hello?
Oh, I got the job, so."
That's how I got on
"The Office"-
- Note to self,
actors.
(all laughing)
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Thanks, Rainn-
- [Kelly] Note to self.